j'ai entendu un bruit Grégory vous êtes
sûr ah je crois que ça frappe voulez que
j'ille
ouvririzar qui nous dérange en pleine
émission de Noë je va essayer de pas
gêner la caméra pour voir qui c'est
est-ce que ce serait pas une surprise
que vous nous avez préparé
Grégory on va voir on va voir qui
c'est ah bonsoir Père Noël c'est le Père
Noël qui nous rejoint dans le 7ère vous
prie allezy allez vous
inster allezy prenez
TV 78 bonsoir bonsoir vous
venez GAB long voyage mais je suis ravi
d'être avec vous ça va c'était pas trop
dur le voyage non j'ai l'habitude pas
trop fatigant on vous laisse vous serrer
à Gabriel juste pour que vous puissiez
bien apparaître à la camé et que on
puisse bien prouver à nos jeunes iinois
que vous êtes bien en cher avec nous en
plateau ce soir voilà alorsah première
question parère Noël est-ce que les
enfants ont été sages cette année
écoutez dans la grande majorité oui mais
mais il reste quelques exceptions alors
il leur reste quelques dodos pour se
rattraper jusqu'à mon
passage tout n'est pas perdu le message
que je passe aux enfants pas très sage
tout n'est pas
perdu vous avez encore 5 jours c dodo et
n'oubliez pas je suis au courant de ce
que vous faites donc vos
parents ils aimeraient bien que je
puisse vous c'est des cadeaux d'accord
donc à vous de jouer donc Gabrielle qui
ne savait pas si elle avait été assez
sage cette année reste encore une chance
il reste encore d' dodo alors est-ce que
la légende elle dit vrai est-ce que vous
mettez du charbon dans les chaussettes
des enfants qui sont pas passage bah
écoutez je je reste taquin je reste
taquin je peux effectivement des fois il
m'arrive de mettre un petit peu de
charbon dans les dans les chaussettes
des enfants à la place à la place
effectivement de friandise bon voilà le
message est clair et sans ambiguïé soyez
SAG soyez SAG voilà et est-ce que les
enfants peuvent vous donner du lait euh
pendant votre tournée quand vous
apportez les cadeaux alors ils peuvent
c'est un peu une légende mais c'est une
légende ou pas fin non mais je vais vous
avouer je suis extrêmement gourmand
alors lorsque j'arrive dans une maison
et qu'il y a un verre de lait et
quelques cookies au
chocolat je vous avoue que je prends le
temps malgré c'est votreandise préféré
les cookies ah les cookies au chocolat
avec un petit ver de lait je prends le
temps de déguster et après je continue
ma tournée donc n'hésitez pas oui je
sais ce qu'il me reste à
faire j'espère que le message est passé
mais d'ailleurs est-ce que les cadeaux
sont prêts ah bien bien sûr bien sûr ça
y est tout est prêt voilà ils sont tous
chargés sauf pour les enfants où on
n'est pas sûr encore qu'il soit très SAG
donc tous les enfants sages la la la la
haute est pleine et puis après au
dernier moment d'accord je vais
effectivement pouvoir charger
les cadeaux pour celles et ceux qui
n'ont pas été complètement sages je me
sens un petit peu visé là donc la haut
c'est quasiment pleine la tournée
mondiale est prête il y a les derniers
ajustements qui sonont fait au dernier
momenti au dernier moment voilà en
fonction de l'attitude des enfants ou
des ou des un petit peu plus grand hein
voilà alors moi je me suis toujours posé
cette question comment est-ce que vous
faites pour construire tous ces cadeaux
parce qu'il y en a ils sont nombreux les
cadeaux bien sûr alors en fait moi ce
que je fais surtout c'est le design les
idées parce qu'en fait je regarde un
petit peu avec quoi s'amusent les
enfants et les moins et est un petit peu
plus un petit peu plus jeune un petit
peu moins jeune et après derrière j'ai
toute une armée de lutin dans mon usine
qui fabrique effectivement tous les
désirs des enfants et des grands voilà
voilà tout seul évidemment ce serait
tout à fait impossible ils font pas trop
de bêtises les lutins ah on les laisse
seul alors parce que je crois que chez
Michel midoro font efftivement moi j'ai
un petit lutin chez moi le lu le lutin
farceur effectivement je sais pas pour
ceux qui connaissent ou connaissent pas
on reçoit un lutin chez soi pendant la
période qui précède Noël et vous les
récupéz c'est ça à la fin quand vous
récupérez les cadeau lors de ma tournée
je dépose le cadeau et je récupère le
lutin et ils sont partis en vacances
c'est bien ça
pendant voilà ils ont travaillé toute
l'année enfit tout est prêt donc c'est
un petit peu leur récompense et comme
ils sont un petit peu farceurs bah
finalement voilà temps en temps ils font
des petites bêtises de la nu
Ilang gteant vous DZ il vont jouer ave
le chat et mais voilà ça reste toujours
dans un bon esprit nous on donnera des
conseils tout à l'heure pour rester en
forme pendant cette période de fête
c'est quoi votre secret à vous cette
longévité écoutez un régime alimentaire
som toute le restant de l'année tout à
fait cordial mais mais un peu frugal
tout de même bon alors évidemment ça me
permet d'avoir les excès pendant la
tournée de cookies évidemment il y a pas
de secret et après je fais tout de suite
beaucoup plus attention le restant de
l'année alors juste vous êtes aidé par
de nombreux lutins mais la Mère Noël
elle fait quoi dans tout ça oh la Mère
Noël elle m beaucoup dans le traitement
des courriers d'accord parce que nous
recevons tout tous les courriers toutes
les listes de tous les enfants et puis
des grands euh il y a énormément de
travail et donc effectivement bah elle
m'aide à répondre parce que nous nous
voulons répondre à toutes les à T tous
les courrier des enfants voilà donc ne
vous inquiétez pas la Mère Noël est
également très très bien occupée J-5
désormais avant votre grande tournée en
tout cas merci beaucoup Père Noël d'être
revenu en plateau par on sait que vous
êtes très occupé en ce moment et vous
avez fait un petit détour par tv78 on
était vraiment ravi d'être avec vous
mais c'était vraiment un grand plaisir
juste un petit aparté vous avez bien
reçu ma lettre sur la console de jeu oui
bien sûr oui oui vous l' bienç d'accord
non c'est juste pour savoir pour pour VO
et vous avez bien reçu mon message pour
les cookies oui oui j'ai bienç donc
effectivement nous avons tous bien reçu
les éléments qu'il fallait